Vernon Smith received a 2002 Nobel
Memorial prize in economic Sciences for
his pioneering work in experimental
economics I caught up with the 96 year
old recently in Southern California and
conducted a long interview about his
life and work that will appear as a
reason podcast here's part of our
conversation about Joe Biden's massive
6.8 trillion dollar budget plan the role
of government spending and Federal
Reserve policy in causing inflation the
bailout of Silicon Valley Bank and why
Smith believes it's very hard to keep
Democrats from wanting to make the world
better by spending other people's money
Vernon Smith thanks for talking to
reason Nick it's great to be here over
the past uh you know four or five years
starting under Donald Trump but the
federal government has just pumped tons
of money into circulation Joe Biden
recently proposed a 6.8 trillion dollar
budget you know we're experiencing
inflation what is the way out of that
kind of situation uh well
I think the first way out
is for the Central Bank not to
accommodate spend thrifts in government
because it's very hard to keep Democrats
wanting to make the world better by
spending other people's money you know
they're really committed to that and the
Republicans to some extent they could
screw up you're not going to be saved
necessarily by them
but the Central Bank you see
they are taking I think more seriously
than they have to their so-called
fiduciary responsibility to the
government they don't have to
accommodate that you see when when
Joe Biden decided to write six hundred
dollar checks per month for all kinds of
people
who who are sitting at home and not
producing any Goods because of covid
well that's not you you can't stimulus
they call us stimulus there's nothing to
stimulate it's it's
it would be like during the second world
war having a stimulus well you didn't
need it you needed the reverse
and and you so you know that's going to
be inflationary and
and of course the FED fully accommodated
that whatever of that debt wouldn't be
held by private citizens they they
bought enough from existing private
citizens that they were willing to buy
the new debt right you know the Federal
Reserve is not supposed to buy it
directly but it's the same and moreover
they buy
interestingly they buy that debt for the
account of Treasury it's called
neutralization they discovered that in
October 2008 that oh wait a minute
that's the way to do it you don't buy it
and hold it in the bank because that
gives the central bank because all of
the banks have increased Reserve
deposits and they will expand credit so
you just transfer it to the treasury
it's really a treasure on this hill
it's like it's as though your your
Banker told you Nick
go and spend whatever you want to if you
don't have enough income about we'll
float bonds to cover that and we'll hold
them in there in your town in our bank
yeah so that's what the federal
government so there's no budget
constraint right it's none none on on
the government so recently the I mean
the Federal Reserve did start raising
the interest rate
um and that had the effect you know most
or this the standard uh Narrative of the
reason why Silicon Valley Bank and
Signature Bank yes you know had a run on
them was because you know the FED hiked
interest rates and suddenly the
long-term bets that these banks have
made made no sense and people were
pulling money out
um so is the Fed starting to do its job
well
in my view it didn't do its job before
and that's why we've got the problem now
yeah it's doing what it always does if
there's inflation you see it starts to
rain but those inflations are are
typically coming
from excessive governments spending
that's accommodated by the Central Bank
in the first place that's where we get
inflation you see it's not coming from
people right it's coming from government
the big stimulus for the inflation came
when people were not home not producing
Goods because of covid and then they
stimulated the economy well there's no
Goods
so the prices basically have to go up
it's just you know it's just arithmetic
uh and and well what I predicted at the
time was that we would have a one-time
increase in prices
it would continue only if the government
continued to do the deficit Finance in
other words now and I don't trust them
not to do that you see and the problem
with inflation you see everything that
the Democrats are trying to do to help
the disadvantaged and the poor is all
taken back because those are the groups
that are so severely hit by inflation so
you're saying when the governor of
California gives you you know a hundred
dollars so that you can afford gas
that now costs more money you're you're
generally not making out to that's right
yeah yeah do you think uh Silicon Valley
Bank uh you know almost immediately when
the run on it happened uh the government
the federal government said don't worry
we're going to cover all deposits we're
you know we're gonna is that a good idea
or is that is that a good rule or a bad
rule that you've got to think of the
consequences you're taking all risk out
of bank deposits Bank the deposits are
the source of investment funds of the
banks so they're there's a source of
capital they don't have to worry about
is just really you know they don't have
to worry about the default on that the
government will take care of it and that
and to me that invites Banks to not
worry very much about doing extremely
riskly Investments
and uh
well there's a lot of
you know risky
potentially High Innovation
uh uh activities that you'd like to see
Capital go to but someone's going to
make a judgment because there's lots of
those alternatives
and most of them are going to go under
so there's a room here for some skill
and investing and if you take all of
that risk out of it I I think that's
extremely dangerous do you worry that
it's I mean right now it's you know two
uh you know Silicon Valley Bank gets
bailed out
um we weren't supposed to do this
anymore right because back during the
financial crisis yeah we figured that
out and we came up with a new regulation
sent out bank would need that
um are you worried that it's you know
this is just a continuation of bailing
out failure well yes and of course the
really big mistake before was to bail
out uh Bank Equity holders the the
presumption was that we were
the thought was and I think that the
government wanted people to believe that
we're bailing out depositors but they
did more than that
because depositors
you see are protected by two things
insurance
prepaid Insurance of the banks plus the
equity in the bank that's what cut is
available to cover as a cushion to to
cover deposit laws and every Bank needs
to take that risk into account to
otherwise this won't get shareholders
they won't buy the common stock you see
unless there's a reasonable that risk is
is not too large and if you take that
all that out I think there's no
equilibrium I I don't I don't know how
that world would even work
foreign